make your head strong huh I think
working hard makes your head strong you
know like when I was a kid I'd stare up
at these streetlights for like 30
minutes and try not to blink right
I'd be squeezing a ball until I thought
my hand was gonna explode I was teaching
myself to be uncomfortable because I
knew being uncomfortable might come in
handy someday like but I wasn't ringing
such yes why you tell me all this
she's making conversation yeah you don't
need soup should I be talking to the
pigeons
so I can become my mother marine that's
how I know it yeah well she is a little
more paintballing a large why not
we shouldn't be goofing on your mother
look man she's my mother
you know she's your mother but mother
should be
these things
no uh
they're from your father lately why just
curious
we're not being around bother you know
at all I said it doesn't
okay
my old man took another Arch's really
bothered me and my mother took walked
through like a different director so my
god
so what'd you do
nothing can do it bother it still does
where you go back every day you take
your lumps
everybody's got lumps it's a lumpy life
period
yeah well luck you got a mother loved
you but she ain't quitting you so you
gotta be listening to her cousin you
listen to them dumbbells on the street
over there you could end up doing a lot
of wrong like me thought it wrong like
you man you made it all the way I know
that was fruit luck but I'll take some
of that free cluck waiting for free
cluck for suckers
we'll work for you yeah
I got a break had this silly me the
Italian stallion
joke some like a joke there backfire if
you want something you got to go out to
get it let me wait for three classes you
know
so you think you got all together
but I'd be climbing into a hole in
cement if I had it all together
no I don't think so
so while you wasting my time we don't
got to talk to me could a woman
like dogs dogs dogs